if he were to go into any house in
County Wexford in the Republic of
Ireland it wouldn't be unusual to still
find a picture of the Pope on the wall
and alongside him a picture of the
former U.S President John F Kennedy I am
proud to be the first American President
to visit Ireland my presence and you're
welcome however
only symbolize the many and the enduring
links which have bound the Irish and the
Americans since the earliest days
Wexford is where the Kennedys came from
and they were a family who made it from
Ireland to the White House in the space
of one generation
but it's not just the candidates every
American president with an Irish
connection has made a huge deal of their
Irish roots and Arcane to capitalize
upon them Ireland is important to
America because of the diaspora and its
best Illustrated I think by the huge
Saint Patrick's Day parades in New York
and Boston in fact they celebrate St
Patrick's Day more than we do here on
the island of Ireland
after all it it was the Irish who built
the Brooklyn Bridge in New York it was
the Irish who helped build the White
House in Washington and the Irish Prime
Minister the taishik of the day is the
only world leader who has a guaranteed
meeting in the Oval Office every year
with the U.S president to mark their
patron saint
so why is this relationship this special
relationship so enduring and what does
it mean for both countries
I'm David Blevins Sky's senior Ireland
correspondent and with political
journalist IFA Moore hello Davis this is
the Sky News Daily
we're outside what's become the world
famous Titanic visitor experience the
number one tourist attraction in Europe
several years in a row and it's here to
commemorate the great ship launched from
these slipways and immortalized in the
film with the same name starring Kate
Winslet and Leonardo DiCaprio
if uh what does this say about Belfast
today when you look around from where
we're standing right now all I can see
is huge you know office blocks um really
modern looking buildings
um a really rejuvenated slept way and
dark lands area and that would remind
you of somewhere in in London or another
big um capital city and I think it
really shows we've just come kind of
from the old Belfast into the new
Belfast this is definitely I think a
study you know who has come over to the
shadow of war and we're seeing you know
foreign direct investment and everything
else that leads to things like this and
I think you know our history in the
north is not just the conflict and the
troubles you know there are other things
that the Northern Ireland is famous for
and it's only kind of outside of the
shadow of violence that you can start to
commemorate those things and start
concentrating on other areas and when
you think about it you know the Titanic
and Ireland is the kind of port in
Belfast supporter where people live in
Ireland to go to America and overseeing
the end looks of Americans coming back
here everyone I think everyone in the
North and the South of Ireland would
have you know U.S relatives the
realities that love and the yes there's
always been such a big connection here
incredible number of people left these
Shores up to 6 million I think left for
the United States all starting in about
1800 because of the Great Potato Famine
and today there are an estimated 45
million people in the United States
claiming Irish ancestry now when you
think about that there's about 4.5
million people living on the island of
Ireland so there are 10 times more Irish
people in America than we have here on
this island and so many people in
America are very proud to be Irish and
identify with this nationality including
of course American Presidents if this
nation had achieved its present
political and economic statue a century
or so ago my great-grandfather might
never have left new Ross John F Kennedy
probably the most famous of the Irish
American Presidents the first Catholic
President of course and since him many
others have followed
including Richard Nixon I can assure you
their greatest purpose and the greatest
goal I have and the greatest purpose and
the greatest goal the American people
have is to play a role to bring peace
not only to America but to all the world
and Barack Obama who I often describe as
the Irish African-American president
well hello
[Music]
the clintons of course who have been
heavily involved in the peace process
the major credit
for the peace process
belongs to the Irish
to the people
to the people who voted
for the Good Friday agreement and this
week President Biden of course he's
arguably the most irish-american
president since John F Kennedy will
visit Northern Ireland he'll go to
Dublin and he will visit his ancestral
homes in live and mayo and I can't
imagine he'll be the last two years
president with an Irish connection
considering as you said that there's 45
million of them killing an Irish
heritage so I wonder what it is and it's
so special when Ireland America where
they have where we have such like an
enduring relationship and to talk a
little bit more about that let's speak
to Dr Richard Johnson who is a senior
lecturer in U.S policy at Queen Mary's
in London and he's written a piece why
do so many U.S presidents like to say
I'm Irish
so Richard why is the White House so
green
well most U.S presidents like to make
some claim to being
irish-american and this has been true of
nearly every president in the post-world
War II period with the exception
curiously enough of Donald Trump who was
very proud of being Scottish but didn't
talk very much about having any Irish
ancestry but what's to me so
funny or interesting about this is that
all of these U.S presidents who have
Irish ancestry
trace the Irish heritage back to roughly
the same same decade so Biden Obama and
John F Kennedy all had their last Irish
ancestor born in Ireland in either the
1830s or 1840s which of course was the
period when so many Irish people left
due to the Potato Famine but they're
reaching quite far back up the family
tree to find that Irish heritage so it
would be fair to say that some are more
Irish than others actually I think
they're probably about as Irish as each
other but from maybe our perspective
over here that feels quite distant but
for for some of these presidents and I
would say with Joe Biden being the
keenest example of this in in recent
times that length of history is still
you know it's still meaningful and uh
and and Biden's Irish identity is
something he holds pretty close to
himself now I know it's obviously to do
with emigration too and extent but I've
heard it said that America is such a
young nation that everyone is grasping
for some sense of Heritage is that part
of what's going on here the romantic
view of the old green Homeland
certainly that the image of Ireland in
the American imagination is uh almost as
kind of
Place almost like an Eden right this
kind of idyllic green uh Emerald Isle
what I think though is sometimes not
commented on but
it's quite important possibly for
someone like Joe Biden is that the
Americans have always had very have had
a lot of difficulty in talking about
class identity and talking about being
working class or middle class and
actually these ethnic identities have
substituted for that to a certain extent
in the 20th century if you were if you
said you were irish-american or
Italian-American that was a way of
signaling that you were not of the
blue-blooded English or northern
European kind of ancestry you came from
a more working class background because
those immigrant communities were
overwhelmingly poor and so for someone
like Joe Biden when he talks about bead
Irish and proud to be Irish I actually
think he's also signaling that he came
from a in his view a kind of ordinary
working class family and and and that's
sort of the language that he uses to
express that but of course there is also
a political Dimension to it given the
importance of the Irish American vote
back home
that's right and this is particularly
true in the Democratic party so if you
went back 30 or 40 years ago an even
higher number and therefore a higher
proportion of Americans would identify
as irish-american and they were
overwhelmingly Democrat Party voters so
they had a huge Sway in the selection of
internal party nominees and this is why
so many democratic presidents have been
Keen to be seen as a friend of the
irish-american community or being
irish-american themselves because they
could be very influential particularly
in say Democratic presidential primaries
this is why Jimmy Carter in 1976 marched
in the St Patrick's Day parade with a
button that said England get out of
Ireland it wasn't really an expression
of his own foreign policy view but it
was a way of trying to win the Irish
vote in the New York Primary in that
election
well let's just talk for a moment about
striking the balance between the foreign
policy View and their desire to be seen
as Irish we remember President Biden
when doorstep by the BBC refusing to
take the question telling them I'm Irish
and when he famously said uh he wouldn't
have anything Orange in in the around
him when he was vice president
does it follow that
Irish American presidents are generally
anti-british
no I don't think it does follow the uh
the the way to see it is that the the
the the the two sides of the coin that
are trying to be addressed here is on
the one side it's good electoral
politics for American Presidents to play
up uh their Irish heritage and their
connection to the Irish Community and
there are a few electoral downsides for
that because there isn't a very strong
constituents in the United States that
is anti-irish it's good politics uh at
home
but I would say that all U.S presidents
of recent times have recognized the
importance of the of the so-called
special relationship between the US and
the UK and they have been Keen not to
jeopardize that that relationship
um uh and so ultimately you know U.S
presidents want in a sense to achieve
The Best of Both Worlds you know they
want to be supportive of Ireland but
they also want to be a good Ally of the
United Kingdom and that can be sometimes
difficult to achieve but in a sense I
think that's why the United States has
positioned itself for example with the
peace process in Northern Ireland as as
the broker because in a sense the U.S
president wants both he wants Ireland to
do well but it also wants to be a good
Ally of the UK
and the United States certainly played a
key role in The Good Friday agreement
with Bill Clinton calling the party
leaders in the small hours of the
morning to get it over the line and of
course it was his peace and voice
Senator George Mitchell who was the
talks chairman who brokered the deal
do you think America therefore sees
itself as a kind of defender of the
peace process and of the Good Friday
agreement and is that why we've seen
such involvement around brexit trading
Arrangements
I think very much so and this is
probably felt particularly keenly by
someone like Joe Biden who has been
around us politics for a very long time
first elected the senator when Richard
Nixon was in the White House
and Biden as a senator was very
interested in foreign policy he was the
chair of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee in the early Northeast late
90s around the same time as the northern
Irish process was going on and worked
very closely with President Clinton
um and so I think Biden actually
probably feels this fairly personally
although he may not have been at the top
table of of the negotiations of the 90
he was not he was probably in the same
room so to so to speak and uh this is
this is perhaps why he has taken as
Keenan interest in the future of the
Good Friday agreement as he has
you've talked about presidents
themselves feeling very Irish and
wanting to capitalize upon their
irishness but is it a case that the
administration as a whole then is more
conscious of the need to balance with
regard to foreign policy
yes and there's always many different
types of interests that have to be
accommodated in in the construction of
of uh viewers foreign policy at the end
of the day uh the Republic of Ireland is
not an especially important strategic
partner of the United States and when
Biden is thinking about the U.S role in
the world with whether that might be on
Ukraine or Afghanistan or the Middle
Middle East you know all of the
different challenges that he is facing
he's unlikely to be contacting the the
tea shop and
um you know expecting Ireland to be
investing a huge amount of resources in
those not least because of Ireland's
historic uh neutrality
so
but Biden is much more likely to be
wanting to have good relations with the
uh with the UK prime minister presidents
are very
Political Animals and they realize the
different constituencies they have to
keep happy to win renomination and
re-election and for their party to do
well but they're also surrounded by uh
people who are appointed because of
their expertise and a wider lens view
perhaps of U.S strategic interests let's
talk a little about this visit
specifically given that Joe Biden is
just the latest in the long line of U.S
presidents to visit Ireland towards the
end of their first term in your view for
him personally is it about capitalizing
on that vote in a bid to win a second
term or is he genuinely uh
pursuing his Irish ancestry I think it's
very genuine for Joe Biden and his long
talked about his interest in his Irish
ancestry part of it as I said I think
was a way of expressing a certain class
story but I think he also has a interest
in his family tree and family uh
Heritage as well in terms of how
literally beneficial it is for
presidents now to play up their Irish
ancestry I think it's fading now uh it's
becoming less and less important there's
still a constituency for it but the the
irish-american population has become a
much more affluent over time and it's no
longer as socially segregated and
isolated in America's American cities
but it's not bad politics so it's not
it's not costly for presidents to do it
and that's why I think you know
presidents like to go to the ancestral
home Barack Obama uh his his ancestor
was from a village in County Offaly
called moneygall
he went to Montego there's now an Obama
Cafe where he was and the ancestral home
you can book visits to it and uh and and
and so on and that's not going to win
you in an election in the US anymore but
there aren't going to be many voters who
wouldn't vote for you because you did
that so it's worth doing I think if you
were going to advise the president
politically speaking and then Barack
Obama's case I think you've got to go
quite some distance back his great great
great great great great grandfather was
a a Shoemaker from Molly goal in County
awfully if I'm not mistaken so to
conclude could I just perhaps ask do you
think even though it's fading that we
will continue for some time to see the
president of the day welcoming the
T-shirt of the day to the White House to
Mark Saint Patrick's week and do you you
think the White House will continue to
emphasize how green the current occupant
whoever that happens to be is
they will I think that this this
connection that the the t-shirt and the
president will will remain I actually
think it's it's its roughest period was
during the Trump presidency when Trump
uh was much less interested in in some
kind of Irish claim uh I don't think he
was Leah varadka's biggest fan uh either
for the Republic of Ireland this is a
relationship that's very much worth
maintaining uh the the t-shirt is the
only world leader who has a guaranteed
visit every year to the White House for
a one-on-one meeting with the president
United States and that's not too bad for
a country of uh half a dozen million
people so uh for now I suspect the the
connection is going to continue so if
while it's clear the Americans have this
romantic notion still about the the old
Emerald Isle their Homeland it's also
about politics absolutely and I think
and everyone would agree that bug
Clinton definitely saw the vote getting
potential into taking a hand in the in
the Northern Ireland peace process as
romantic as it is I think everyone knows
that the player of the Irish American
vote is always going to be a big draw
for the president thanks Ethan Moore
political journalist for your time today
thanks also to Dr Richard Johnson I'm
David Blevins and this is the Sky News
Daily
foreign